Wenn das hier nicht das erste
maiLab-Video ist, das ihr schaut,
seid ihr wohl Freunde
der Wissenschaft
oder Freunde der Sonne.
Ihr verlasst euch nicht
auf persönliche Meinungen,
ihr verlasst euch
auf Daten und Zahlen.
Aber ich sage euch, dass man sich
auf gar nichts verlassen kann.
Aber im Ernst.
Zahlen, Grafiken, Statistiken
können irreführend sein.
Man kann Statistiken unbewusst
missverständlich einsetzen
oder auch ganz bewusst
damit manipulieren.
Was steckt hinter einem Wimpernserum
mit 14 Prozent mehr Wachstum?
Oder wenn eine Anti-Aging-Creme
43 Prozent freie Radikale reduziert.
Was genau heißt es,
wenn drei Stück Bacon pro Tag
das Darmkrebsrisiko
um 20 Prozent erhöhen?
Sobald man eine Zahl sieht,
denkt man sich: Okay, alles klar.
Aber oft ist gar nichts klar.
Es sei denn, man kennt sich etwas
mit Statistik aus.
Holt euch 'n Tee, macht es euch
gemütlich, wir steigen durch.
(Knall)
Freunde der Sonne, ihr habt euch
dieses Video gewünscht.
Im Video über die Kita-
und Schulöffnungen
hatte ich gefragt, ob ihr ein Video
zu Statistik sehen wollt.
Eine überwältigende Mehrheit
hat gesagt:
Oh, ein bisschen Statistik,
da sag ich nicht nein.
Leider kann ich euch die
Umfrageergebnisse nicht zeigen.
Ich hab keinen Screenshot gemacht.
Und YouTube hat die Umfragen
abgeschafft. Rest in Peace.
Das heißt, vielleicht lüge ich ja
und ihr wolltet nicht
über Statistik abnerden. Hehe.
Das führt mich zur Anmerkung:
Es geht in diesem Video nicht um
gefälschte Zahlen oder Statistiken.
Nein, es geht
um ganz korrekte Zahlen,
die aber durch eine missverständliche
Darstellung
völlig falsche Rückschlüsse
ziehen lassen.
Als Schutz hilft nur:
Herzlich willkommen dazu.
Wir haben alltagsnützliche Basics
rausgesucht, wir beginnen mit der:
Damit meint man, dass die
tatsächlichen Einzelwerte
um den Mittelwert herum verteilt,
also verstreut sind.
Lässt man diese Streuung
bei der Darstellung weg,
werden Zahlen schnell irreführend.
Folgendes Beispiel.
Das ist eines dieser Wimpernseren,
die das eigene Wimpernwachstum
ankurbeln sollen.
Hier wurde ein Experiment gemacht,
bei dem die Anwenderinnen am Ende
14,21 Prozent
mehr Wimpernwachstum hatten.
Was auch immer
mehr Wimpernwachstum heißt.
Dazu kommen wir später.
Nehmen wir erst mal an,
dass zumindest die Zahl 14,21 Prozent
so stimmt.
Oder hier: ein Experiment
zu einer Anti-Aging-Creme.
Ein "full-thickness"
3D-Hautmodell-Testverfahren
wurde hier durchgeführt.
Es klingt sciencey.
Die Sonnenbrandzellen
wurden um 40 Prozent,
freie Radikale
um 43 Prozent reduziert.
Sehen wir davon ab, dass nicht klar
ist, was "Sonnenbrandzellen" sind.
Und nehmen wir auch hier an,
dass die Zahlen an sich stimmen.
Dass das genauso gemessen wurde.
Dann sind diese Graphen
ziemlich nichtssagend.
Warum, das erklärt sich gleich
von selbst.
Davor müssen wir die Streuung
besser verstehen.
Beispiel: Nehmen wir das fiktive
Videospiel "SuperMairio".
Jetzt stellt man fest,
dass bei SuperMairio
Männer im Schnitt
14.000.605 Punkte erzielen,
Frauen dafür 14.000.606 Punkte.
Das heißt, Frauen erzielen im Schnitt
einen Punkt mehr.
Das klingt nach einem bedeutungslos
kleinen Unterschied.
Ihr würdet nicht davon ausgehen,
dass wegen einem Punkt
bei einer Größenordnung
von 14 Millionen
Frauen wirklich besser in SuperMairio
sind als Männer.
Richtig. Anders ist es
bei diesem fiktiven Beispiel.
Sagen wir, auf Planet X
gibt es Aliens,
und zwar männliche
und weibliche Aliens.
Die männlichen Aliens
sind im Schnitt 1,79 Meter groß,
und die weiblichen Aliens
im Schnitt 1,66 Meter.
Dann sind die Alien-Männer im Schnitt
13 Zentimeter größer
als die Alien-Frauen.
In diesem Beispiel
sind diese 13 Zentimeter
ja ein nennenswerter Unterschied.
Es geht hier nicht
um 1 von 14 Millionen,
sondern um 13 von 179
beziehungsweise 166.
Bei SuperMairio ist also
dieser eine Punkt Unterschied
nicht nennenswert.
Bei den Aliens sind es
die 13 Zentimeter schon. Richtig?
Falsch.
Genaugenommen können wir
diese Unterschiede nur bewerten,
wenn wir die Größe der Streuung
kennen.
Diese Info fehlt uns bisher.
Gut, bei SuperMairio ist es nur
plausibel, davon auszugehen,
dass die Punktestände im
Größenbereich von 14 Millionen
im Tausender- oder
Zehntausenderbereich streuen.
Aber genaugenommen kennen wir
SuperMairio ja gar nicht.
Theoretisch ist es möglich, dass die
Punktestände nicht stark streuen.
Etwa, weil man im ersten Level
14.000.600 Punkte bekommt.
Quasi als Willkommensgeschenk.
Und danach nur noch
einen Punkt pro Level.
Ich hab mir das Spieldesign
nicht ausgedacht.
(off:) Hast du wohl!
Das würde aber bedeuten,
dass die Streuung so klein ist,
dass Frauen möglicherweise
doch besser in SuperMairio sind.
Damit will ich nur klarmachen:
Dass 1 im Vergleich
zu 14.000.605 so klein ist,
ist gar nicht der springenden Punkt.
Sondern es ist die Streuung,
auf die es hier ankommt.
Noch klarer wird es bei den Aliens.
Denn wisst ihr was?
Die Alien-Männer und Alien-Frauen
auf Planet X
sind im Durchschnitt genauso groß,
wie die Männer und Frauen
auf diesem Planeten.
Für uns können wir die Streuung
aus unserem Alltag einschätzen.
Also, ich bin mi meinen 1,58
eher am unteren Ende der Frauenskala.
Am oberen Ende wäre
die Basketballerin Satou Sabally
mit 1,93.
Kurzer Zwischenschub.
Ich sitz am Schnitt
und hab festgestellt,
dass sie eventuell auch 1,89
beziehungsweise 1,87 groß ist.
Satou Sabally ist groß,
das steht fest.
Aber ja, so viel zum Thema Streuung.
Aber die meisten Frauen
sind zwischen 1,60 und 1,70.
Aber auf Planet X
sieht das ganz anders aus.
Hier sind Alien-Frauen
zwischen 50 Zentimeter
und 3,-noch-was groß.
Und innerhalb dieser Spanne
auch normal verteilt.
Bei den Alien-Männern ist es ähnlich.
Betrachtet man die Mittelwerte,
scheint die Situation auf der Erde
und auf Planet X genau gleich.
Trägt man die Streuung
als Fehlerbalken ein,
dann sieht das so aus.
Die Streuung innerhalb
der Alien-Frauen und Alien-Männer
ist jeweils viel größer als der
Unterschied der beiden Mittelwerte.
Ihr seht direkt, dass der
durchschnittliche Größenunterschied
zwischen Alien-Männern
und Alien-Frauen in der Praxis
sicher eine viel
unbedeutendere Rolle spielt
als auf der Erde.
Nicht nur in der Praxis
ist die Streuung bedeutend,
sondern auch, um zu bewerten,
wie aussagekräftig
bestimmte Daten sind.
Von der Streuung hängt auch ab,
wie groß meine Stichprobe sein muss.
Bei 'ner kleinen Streuung
kann die Stichprobe auch klein sein.
Im Extremfall, wenn wir
gar keine Streuung hätten,
auf Planet X wären alle Alien-Männer
gleich groß
und alle Alien-Frauen
wären genau gleich groß,
dann würde eine Stichprobe
von jeweils eins reichen,
um repräsentativ
für Planet X zu sein.
Aber je größer die Streuung,
desto größer
muss die Stichprobe sein,
für eine repräsentative Messung.
Wenn ich beim Wimpernserum lese,
dass die Testgruppe
aus 25 Anwenderinnen bestand,
und gerade mal fünf
das Placebo-Serum bekamen,
übersehen wir das großzügigerweise
und bleiben bei den 25.
Da würden viele schon denken:
Was für ein Quatsch.
25 ist ja viel zu wenig.
Aber auch nur 25 Probanden können
aussagekräftige Ergebnisse liefern.
Oder zumindest interessante Hinweise,
wenn die Streuung
entsprechend klein ist.
Über die Streuung erfahren wir hier
aber nichts.
Bei der Creme kein Hinweis
zu Streuung oder Probengröße.
In der Wissenschaft dürfte man
die Streuung nie weglassen.
Sie ist auch bei der statistischen
Auswertung wichtig.
Je größer die Streuung ist, desto
schwieriger ist es festzustellen,
ob ein Unterschied nur zufällig
oder tatsächlich echt ist.
So passiert es nicht selten,
dass beim Testen
eines neuen Medikaments
zwischen der Test- und Placebogruppe
ein Unterschied gefunden wird,
der sich aber nach der Auswertung
als nicht statistisch signifikant
herausstellt.
Also eher zufällig ist.
Ohnehin ist es höchst
unwahrscheinlich,
dass man bei einer Test-
und Placebogruppe
genau denselben Wert misst.
Sei es bei einem Medikament
oder einem Wimpernserum.
Die Mittelwerte alleine
sagen also wenig aus,
die Frage ist,
ob das zufällig ist oder nicht.
Wie das hier dargestellt ist,
könnten die 14 Prozent Wachstum
zufällige Schwankung sein.
Genauso diese beiden Graphen.
Ohne Fehlerbalken
sagt mir das gar nichts.
Beim Laien bleibt aber
der Eindruck zurück,
dass hier wissenschaftliche
Experimente durchgeführt wurden
mit scheinbarem Erfolg.
Zahlen muss man also
nicht mal fälschen,
um sie zu schönen.
Wir haben uns auch gefragt,
was diese Linien bedeuten sollen.
zumal die Achsen
nicht beschriftet sind.
Das soll wohl
wissenschaftlich aussehen.
Es gibt noch mehr Probleme
mit dem Serum, dazu später.
Wenn wir im Alltag schon so viel
mit Durchschnitten und Mittelwerten
hantieren,
sollten wir die richtig verstehen.
Jetzt der zweite Punkt:
90 Prozent der Befragten halten sich
für bessere Autofahrer
als der Durchschnitt.
So was in der Art kommt raus,
wenn man Leute befragt
und hat mit der
"Illusory Superiority" zu tun,
dem Phänomen,
dass man sich selbst überschätzt.
Darum geht es nicht,
sondern um Folgendes:
Rechnerisch ist es durchaus möglich,
dass 90 Prozent besser sind
als der Durchschnitt.
Schauen wir uns das an.
Unter Durchschnitt
verstehen wir in der Regel:
Wenn wir die Durchschnittsgröße
von neun Leuten bestimmen möchten,
messen wir jeden
und teilen die Summe durch neun.
Das ist der Durchschnitt,
wie wir ihn kennen und lieben.
Genauer gesagt
das arithmetische Mittel.
Allerdings ist dieses arithmetische
Mittel manchmal etwas doof.
Und es gibt eine andere Art
von Durchschnitt,
die manchmal besser ist.
Wir stellen dieselben
neun Leute der Größe nach auf
und anstatt jeden einzeln zu messen,
messen wir nur die Größe der Person
in der Mitte.
Oder wenn es 'ne gerade Zahl ist,
nimmt man den Mittelwert,
das arithmetische Mittel,
zwischen den beiden Mittleren.
Diese Art von Durchschnitt
nennt sich Median.
Liegen das arithmetische Mittel
und der Median nah beieinander,
ist es im Alltag egal,
welches Maß man angibt.
Aber jetzt tauschen wir mal
einen der neun Leute
gegen Robert Wadlow aus,
den größten Menschen der Welt.
2,72 Meter war er groß.
Dann verzerrt der ja den Schnitt,
das arithmetische Mittel nach oben.
Der Median verändert sich gar nicht.
Er ist weniger empfindlich
gegenüber Ausreißern.
Bei ungleichen Verteilungen ist
der Median der bessere Mittelwert
als unser arithmetisches Mittel.
Etwa bei Gehältern.
Denken wir an das Durchschnittsgehalt
der Deutschen,
haben wir meist nicht auf dem Schirm,
dass die Verteilung so aussieht.
Es gibt einen langen Schwanz
an wenigen Hochverdienern.
Wenn etwa wenige Milliardäre
noch reicher werden,
verzerrt das das arithmetische Mittel
nach oben,
der Median bleibt aber gleich.
Da die meisten von uns
keine Milliardäre sind,
ist der Median für uns
viel relevanter.
Ähnlich ist es bei Hauspreisen,
wo wenige, aber exorbitant teure
Luxusvillen
das arithmetische Mittel hochziehen,
den Median aber nicht.
Kommen wir zurück
zum Autofahrerbeispiel.
Wie können theoretisch 90 Prozent
der Autofahrer
besser sein als der Durchschnitt?
Wenn wir Autofahren bewerten könnten,
etwa mit Noten,
müssten wir uns
folgendes Szenario vorstellen:
Indem die meisten Autofahrer
'ne Zwei haben
oder 'ne Zwei minus, 'ne Zwei plus,
und es gibt nur ganz wenige
Autofahrer, die grottenschlecht sind
und 'ne glatte Sechs haben.
Die wenigen ziehen
den Durchschnitt runter auf 2,4.
Aber 90 Prozent der Autofahrer sind
mit ihrer Zwei minus oder besser
besser als der Durchschnitt.
Oder: Die meisten Menschen haben
überdurchschnittlich viele Ohren.
Denn wenn sich auch nur ein
Vincent van Gogh ein Ohr abschneidet,
zieht er damit den Durchschnitt
der Ohrenzahl aller Menschen
auf leicht unter zwei.
Und damit bin ich mit meinen vollen
zwei Ohren überdurchschnittlich.
Ihr versteht das Prinzip,
bei so 'ner Autofahrerumfrage
interessiert uns eigentlich,
wie schätzen sich die Menschen
in Bezug auf den Median ein.
Aber selbst,
wenn man die Frage so formuliert:
"Gehören Sie zu der besseren Hälfte
der Autofahrer?",
kommt ein ganz ähnliches Ergebnis
raus.
Auf die Selbstüberschätzung
von Menschen ist Verlass.
Ein letzter,
oft missverstandener Punkt:
Hier ein Bericht der britischen BBC
vom letzten Jahr.
Wer am Tag statt einem
drei Streifen Bacon isst,
hat ein um 20 Prozent
erhöhtes Darmkrebsrisiko.
Und obwohl diese Zahlen stimmen,
wurden die Medienberichte
der entsprechenden Studie
im "British Medical Journal"
scharf kritisiert.
Auch hier
fehlen wieder Informationen,
das macht die Zahlen
missverständlich.
Unter 10.000 Briten,
die normal Bacon essen,
also hier ein Stück pro Tag,
gibt es 40 Fälle von Darmkrebs.
Bei normalem Verhalten
beträgt das individuelle Risiko,
an Darmkrebs zu erkranken,
0,40 Prozent.
Bei den Vielfleischessern,
die etwa drei Streifen Bacon
pro Tag essen,
gibt es unter 10.000 Briten 48 Fälle.
Die relative Erhöhung von 40 auf 48
sind also tatsächlich
20 Prozent mehr.
Aber das absolute Risiko
für jeden Einzelnen
hat sich dabei lediglich
von 0,40 auf 0,48 Prozent erhöht.
Aber die Schlagzeile "Drei Stück
Bacon erhöhen das Darmkrebsrisiko
von 0,40 Prozent auf 0,48 Prozent",
das ist jetzt nicht so erwähnenswert.
Deswegen lassen sich selbst
angesehene Medienhäuser wie die BBC
oder manchmal sogar Forscher
dazu hinreißen,
nur das relative Risiko zu nennen.
Kommen wir noch mal kurz
auf den Wimperngraph zurück.
Ich finde es sehr verdächtig,
dass hier 14 Prozent mehr
Wimpernwachstum steht,
und nicht etwa 14 Prozent längere
Wimpern oder dichtere Wimpern.
Das könnte nämlich
auch so was heißen wie:
Wenn ohne Serum die Wimpern
in 'nem bestimmten Zeitraum
einen Millimeter wachsen,
mit Serum aber 14 Prozent mehr,
das heißt, 1,14 Millimeter,
dann ist das ja in Bezug
auf die Gesamtwimpernlänge
recht überschaubar.
Da überlege ich mir,
ob ich dafür mein Geld ausgebe.
Genauso ist es für
potenzielle Baconliebhaber
für den Alltag relevanter,
das absolute Risiko zu kennen.
Man muss sich fragen:
Bin ich dazu bereit,
zwei Stück Bacon mehr zu essen,
wenn dafür das Darmkrebsrisiko
von 0,40 auf 0,48 Prozent steigt.
Wobei dazusagen möchte,
dass gerade bei Gesundheitsfragen
auch sehr kleine absolute
Prozentsätze
nicht so ohne Weiteres
verworfen werden sollten.
Denn 0,08 Prozent
von 80 Millionen Deutschen
sind immerhin 64.000 Darmkrebsfälle,
die man verhindern könnte,
durch etwas so Vermeidbares
wie statt drei Stück Bacon
nur noch ein Stück Bacon pro Tag
zu essen.
Wenn das so stimmt, wär das ja super.
Zahlen sind also nicht gleich Zahlen.
Man braucht immer Kontext und etwas
statistisches Grundverständnis.
Ich hoffe, wir konnten euch da
etwas behilflich sein
mit diesem Video.
Das war kein vollständiger
Statistik-Crashkurs,
aber es waren drei Basics,
die Meiner Meinung nach im Alltag
ganz gut einzusetzen sind.
Hat man das einmal auf dem Schirm,
sieht man diese Dinge überall.
Sind euch schon Beispiele
eingefallen?
Schreibt sie gerne in die Kommentare.
Eigentlich wollten wir im Video auch
die Statistik hinter der Sensitivität
und Spezifität
von Corona-Antikörpertests machen.
Was heißt es eigentlich,
wenn ein Test
99 Prozent spezifisch ist?
Aber dann dachte ich, es ist cooler,
dazu ein ganzes Video zu machen.
Ein Video über Antikörpertests
kommt als nächstes -
mit statistischem Fokus.
Habt ihr dazu Fragen, schreibt sie in
die Kommentare mit dem #antikörper.
Hier verlink ich unser Video
zur Frage:
"Ist ein bisschen Alkohol
nicht doch gesund?"
Da spielt Statistik auch eine Rolle.
Schaut mal bei Phil Laude vorbei,
in seinem Video "Almans gegen
Rassismus" bin ich auch dabei.
Wir sehen uns in zwei Wochen.